the president said yesterday about this
this treatment hydroxychloroquine which
is recommended for malaria but not for
Kobe 19 there's a US correspondent
Amanda Walker just remind us of what the
president said about that and the
reaction yeah I there were gasps audible
gasps in the room of reporters when he
volunteered the information that he is
actually taking hydroxychloroquine
himself and has been for over a week and
he sort of relished the shock value of
that he knew that there would be a lot
of controversy because this is a drug
that is unproven when it comes to the
treatment of coronavirus treatment of
coronavirus that's a very important
specification here because that's what
the studies have been into so far as far
as we know the president who's being
tested every day does not have corona
virus he has no symptoms and he's taking
this drug as a preventative measure now
as far as we're aware there are no
studies about its efficacy as a
preventive drug but for months now he's
really been pushing hydroxychloroquine
and back in April was really the peak of
that when he said take it what do you
have to lose there was a lot of
criticism then especially when the study
started coming out one study in
particular in veterans in Virginia said
that it actually increased the mortality
rate in coronavirus patients and
numerous studies since then have
basically said that it has no impact
that there is no evidence that it helps
that it treats coronavirus but despite
that what you see now is the president
going to great lengths to prove that he
is right now there's been criticism from
medical experts saying that it's
irresponsible for him to use his
platform to say to people take this drug
when there are some potentially very
harmful side effects the Food and Drug
Administration has said that it
shouldn't be taken outside of a hospital
setting that it has potential impact on
the heart rhythm and people with kidney
disease so a whole host of complex
medical issues potentially but that
hasn't stopped the president doubling
down on this today a lot of our
frontline workers take it because it
possibly and I think it does but you
know
people are gonna have to make up their
own mind plus it doesn't hurt people
it's been out on the market for 60 or 65
years for malaria lupus and other things
I think it gives you an additional level
of safety but you can ask many doctors
are in favor of it
many frontline workers won't go there or
unless they have the hydroxy and so
again this is an individual decision to
make but it's had a great reputation and
if it was somebody else other than me
people would say gee isn't that smart
extraordinary but other questions being
asked him and about how he's getting his
hands on it one imagines it's the
President of the United States even if
he wants to take an aspirin it has to be
run past his medical advisers and he
obviously can't nip down the local
drugstore to get his hands on it exactly
so there's been a this letter from a
White House physician which was pretty
vague and it was released after he said
yesterday that he was taking the drug
and it didn't talk about what he was
prescribed when he was prescribed how
much he's prescribed it was purely and
that had been sort of an agreement
between the physician and the president
that basically the benefits outweighed
the risks Donald Trump has clearly heard
stories from people and that was his
answer when he was asked okay there's no
scientific evidence supporting this
where are you getting your evidence and
your confidence really that this is
something that you should be taking as
the president of the United States and
encouraging millions of Americans to
take and he simply said stories people
calling him writing letters saying that
it was working for them and that's what
he's basing this on so lots of criticism
from the scientific community who say
it's not that simple also criticism very
unusually from Fox News almost
immediately after the president said he
was taking this drug one of their hosts
said if you are in an at-risk group
because a lot of their audience that
much older do not take this drug it may
kill you
so that was very unusual the president
didn't like that criticism and he
doesn't like the overall criticism that
he's getting this wrong when it comes to
this drug so he's taken it to these new
heights of actually saying that he's
taking it himself
my goodness me okay I'm and keep an eye
on that cabinet meeting for us
to Walker there now a new global study
suggests carbon emissions drop by 17% at
the height of the coronavirus lockdown
however the professor leading the
analysis has played down hopes he could
help nations meet the 2015 Paris
agreement target of trying to limit
global warming to 1.5 degrees
they tell Sky News that would require a
similar fall in carbon emissions every
single year for decades sky science
correspondent Thomas Moore reports on
the challenge of meeting climate targets
after coronavirus the return to work an
in Manchester a new way of commuting
roads are being given over to cyclists
and pedestrians safer than crowding
together on public transport and Oh